LES VOGEL: All right.
So welcome to our Google
Developer Relations office
hours hang out.
And what else can I say?
I'm Les Vogel.
This is Osama Alami and
Christian whose last name I
will not pronounce.
CHRISTIAN KRUZKE: It's
simple, Kurzke.
LES VOGEL: Yes.
You'd think I'd have
it by now.
OK.
And just got joined by Chris.
CHRIS: Hello.
LES VOGEL: Welcome.
All right.
So since Leon was here, and
he's got four questions.
Ah, and Paul Saxman and Joel,
another name I'm not going to
pronounce, has just arrived.
Let's see, so Leon's first
question is about opening up a
way to open source
the ILS app.
Any update?
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
We're talking about it.
It's more likely at least in
the nearer term, that we'll
release parts of it.
So I've been kind of
recommending if you have a
specific question to kind of
post it on Stack Overflow.
And then we can potentially
follow up with some code on
Stack Overflow.
Longer term, we'd like
to open source it.
It's just a matter of kind of
cleaning up the code and
making sure it's usable.
So I think I was kind
of mistaken, there
was an issue I think.
It was kind of old news with
iOS or Apple's restriction
about open sourcing apps
in the market.
But I don't think that's
an issue any longer.
So I think they changed their
licence quite a while ago.
So it's certainly doable.
We're thinking about
working on it.
And in the near term, post
in Stack Overflow.
LEON: It's just that from an
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] point of a
view, it's kind of
complicated.
It's going to take more than
just a snippet of code to get
things going.
So if there is anything you
could release , it would have
to be something that is
functional in terms of sending
a code to the device.
That would be the minimum.
It doesn't need to have all the
UI and all the things the
remote actually does.
But yeah, there is so much
messaging and so much stuff
about protocol you need
to get up and running.
It would be nice to get some
feedback on Stack Overflow,
but practically I think
it's going to take
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
So I was kind of thinking that
the more complex part of it
was the parent protocol.
Would you agree with that?
If we were going
to prioritize--
LEON: Yes.
I would say that's right.
There's a lot of messaging.
There is a lot of
security stuff.
Yes.
That would make sense, yes.
I was kind of surprised
the first time I
looked at the code.
I was kind of expecting probably
more of that to be
inside of a library.
But in the activities there's
a lot of work just to handle
all those messages.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
And I think getting the SSL
encryption right is kind of
complex as well.
So, yeah, I'll take it back
to kind of the product
development team and kind of
see if we can get a little
more traction on getting
that out there.
LEON: OK.
Great.
Thanks.
PAUL SAXMAN: We'll definitely
post some updates.
LES VOGEL: Let's see.
Chris, you had a question?
CHRIS: No.
I don't really have
a question.
I've been building stuff with
the Samsung TV SDK, and I
would like to port that
application to the Google TV
device that I have. So I'm
just hanging out to
learn more about it.
I don't have a specific
question.
LES VOGEL: OK.
No problem.
You're welcome to.
If it gets up to 10 people, then
I might ask you to drop
off and join the
live broadcast.
CHRIS: That's great.
Yeah.
I wasn't sure.
I've not used hang
outs before.
So if I need to do that,
it's no problem.
LES VOGEL: But on the other
hand, no problem.
OK.
I'll move on.
LEON: Les, can I
jump in there?
LES VOGEL: Sure.
LEON: So my understanding that
Samsung apps are basically
HTML apps, right.
So Les posted a nice article on
that on PhoneGap solution.
So that looked like an option
for him to look at right?
LES VOGEL: Actually, PhoneGap
and also if you're doing
video, there is a video player
that ties in with our earlier
Google TV sample code.
But PhoneGap for a non-video
app is very
cool and very simple.
And we support many of
the iOS style meta
tags and other tags.
So, yeah.
Take a look under
developers.googl
e.com/tv/android/articles,
I think.
developers.google.com/tv, and
you'll find articles.
CHRIS: OK.
Great.
Thank you.
LES VOGEL: And we've also just
published my stream.
So I haven't published an awful
lot in the last week.
So if you just look at all
my postings, it's there.
OK?
Brian.
BRIAN: Hi guys.
I've got two questions.
I'm wondering if you can turn
the display off from an
application?
So like I want to turn off my
TV and have it turn on at 6
o'clock every day
or something.
LES VOGEL: Oh, OK.
You want Alarm Clock.
Yeah that depends on the OEM.
And do we know--
OSAMA ALAMI: So right now the
problem is if it's running on
something like the Blu-ray
player or the Review, you
would basically need to be able
to send HTMI commands.
There is like CFC
specification.
Unfortunately, we don't have
exposed APIs for that.
And even the internal support,
as Les said, some OEMs
implement it.
So the Sony Blu-ray player, for
example, can turn on and
off the Sony TV. But if you
connect a different TV to it
then it's already not
going to work.
And there is no developer APIs
that are exposed for it.
BRIAN: OK.
My second question, I guess, is
there any hope of getting
an SDK for the Logitech cameras
that you can hook up
to the Reviews?
Or any camera API?
LES VOGEL: That would be a
question for Logitech.
PAUL SAXMAN: In terms of any
APIs, so I'm still toying
around with this.
My original impression is
that we didn't really
support USB host mode.
But doing more testing, it looks
like we do support it a
little more fully than
I had thought.
So there is a possibility that
you could actually write
drivers using USB host mode to
write drivers for a video
camera in Java.
The issue is that it's rather
complex to do that.
And you'd actually have to do
video processing in Java,
which is also really slow,
or potentially
would be really slow.
But we're kind of playing
around with it
a little more lately.
So we potentially will have
some updates on that.
This is also related to a
question that Leon had earlier
about the serial devices.
And it looks like serial devices
might be supported
actually via USB host mode.
So if you're following the
thread on the Android, the EDK
post that I put in, if the USB
device is actually recognized
by the USB host APIs, which all
devices should be, then
you can actually write your
own driver for it.
LES VOGEL: The other thing you
might consider doing is moving
to a Wi-Fi or an ethernet
camera.
It has its own compression.
Because if it has its own
compression then you don't
have to do anything
on the box.
Some of the newer boxes that
will ship this year have
enough horsepower to do
compression in the box.
But the Review and the existing
Sonys don't really
have enough juice.
BRIAN: Thanks.
LEON: Can I jump in?
Can I get back to Paul about
that [? serial ?] interface.
I looked at the article
you posted on Google+.
LES VOGEL: Let's see, if I could
ask Matthew to turn down
his speaker.
Or turn his microphone--
cool.
Thank you.
LEON: So I looked at that
article that you posted on
Google+, Paul, and in my
understanding, it still
requires this library beyond
the Java code.
And the library, as far as I
could see, is going to be
native code.
Since we don't have a compiler
for that, I couldn't see a way
around that.
At least the rest of the
code is Java, yes.
But it was relying on this
intermediate thing to put the
USB in kind of a
[? serial-like ?] mode.
That's how I read
that article.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
I mean there are actually two
of those articles in there.
One of them was actually
doing that.
It was compiling
the FTDI serial
drivers into the kernel.
And then the other one made it
sounds like it was a little
bit different.
Like you could actually set up
the protocol handling actually
in Java itself.
I'm still toying
around with it.
But if you grab that code
actually from the one in my
post, if I posted the correct
one, it should be a native
Java app, a native
Android Java app.
LEON: Yeah.
I saw that two ways.
The two ways were basically
relying on a driver, which is
obviously not practical unless
you route the device.
But the other one, I assumed
that there was a native
component so I didn't actually
go further than that.
But I'll give the Java
code a try just
to see if it's enough.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
I'm doing the same thing with
the [? Arduino ?] because I'm
trying to communicate.
It's the same FTDI--
I think it's FTDI--
serial chip on the device.
So I think that you were talking
about potentially.
So we'll see how it goes.
LES VOGEL: OK.
We'll go to Chris.
If I can find my mouse without
killing my video.
Or excuse me, to Will.
You have a bunch.
WILL: Yeah, one of my question
was about Google TV evolving
and Smart TV. Like will Google
TV eventually be able to tell
what shows I've watched?
And make suggestions
based on the shows.
So if I'm watching Fringe
then it can
recommend Alcatraz to me.
Something like that.
PAUL SAXMAN: There are some
suggestions built into the TV
and Movies application.
But there isn't anything along
the lines of what you
described that's exposed
to developers.
In terms of general product
plans, we typically don't make
comments on what we
are planning.
So I can't really add
anything more.
WILL: Can you talk about the
future of Google TV being a
part of an actual cable box that
you get from a provider?
I think this would be great.
So basically, when you sign up
for cable, you have a Google
TV box right there.
That would be perfect.
And with Onlive as part of
Google TV, you have a console
basically there too.
That's something I would
love to see happen.
I'd like to hear what you
guys think about that.
PAUL SAXMAN: Well,
it'd be great.
But, again, we can't talk
about what any of
the OEMs are up to.
WILL: Gottcha.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
We've announced new devices at
CES from a of number of OEMs,
but all the announcements were
around Buddy Boxes, Blue-ray
players, and TV.
WILL: And the other one,
I don't know if this is
appropriate.
But I have a Google TV app.
I won't say the name of it.
I have a request list that's
super long right now, and I
need some help.
So if anybody is out there, and
they want to do some side
work with Google TV, contact
me on Google+
because I need some help.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, I think we're
reviewing your app this
week in fact.
WILL: Cool, I appreciate it.
I would love to be in
the future area.
LES VOGEL: Cool.
All right.
Let's see, I know Leon
has another one.
And I'm not tracking everybody's
questions.
So I'll go back to Leon and then
feel free to post to the
chat window if you've
got a question.
OK.
LEON: I guess this is still
related to some of these
accessory things.
So I've ordered an ADK and I've
also ordered on Arduino
with ethernet.
I'm just wondering for the short
term would it be better
for me to concentrate on kind of
networking type accessories
until there's some good solution
for physically
attached accessories or
what do you think?
LES VOGEL: Are you meaning for
creating a product or for
playing or--
LEON: Well, basically for adding
accessories to Google
TV. Because I want to be able
to control devices.
And since it's still up in the
air whether we can actually
control an Arduino or get all
the capabilities at least in
the short term.
So I'm thinking maybe
concentrating on a networking
solution if there's another
Arduino or other type device
that you can talk to, it'd be
a better short term solution
until there is kind of a real
solution for talking to real
accessories.
PAUL SAXMAN: I'd say I think
network over TCP or own
network is actually probably
the easiest way.
It's also the most expensive
way, unfortunately, just
because usually like the
ethernet shields are like $30,
$40 or something like that.
Or if you get the integrated
ethernet Arduino.
So it's a little more
expensive obviously.
So I think it should be pretty
straightforward.
I've never really played with
the protocol like doing DCP
communication on Arduino,
but I'm sure there is
lots of code for it.
So I'd say it's a good probably
near term solution.
LES VOGEL: What might make a
good business or at least a
way to help you is to approach
the manufacturers of the
devices you are interested in.
And say this is what you're
doing and get them to, at the
very least, contract or do a
trade for devices or a future
sale or something like that.
LEON: Yeah, the two devices I
wanted to play with was, I
think I mentioned the one
before, the light bulb, the
Wi-Fi light bulb.
Unfortunately, it's still
not available.
And the second one is a z-wave
controller, but it's USB-based.
And that's really the only
option unless you do some
terrible hacks with some of
their remote controls, which I
want to avoid.
I want to make a plug and
play solution so any
consumer could use that.
So on both levels, things aren't
quite ready I would say
from an accessory
point of view.
LES VOGEL: Yeah.
Well, it was just a thought.
Let's see, Will wanted to
ask Matthew a question.
WILL: And he mentioned Simple TV
in his comments on Google+.
And I don't know what that is.
I was just wondering
what that is.
LES VOGEL: OK.
I'll ask Matthew, you
want to answer?
MATTHEW: Yes.
Sure.
I was just getting ready to type
that in the chat window.
I'm sure these OEMs that are
working on future hardware
will likely build something
into one of these devices.
But Simple TV is coming out with
something to stream off
air content into MPEG-4.
I'm wondering if you guys are
aware of any others that have
come up with similar kinds of
solutions that are out there
to be able to take advantage
of that content that's
available off air at
a very good price?
LES VOGEL: Everyone is
shaking their heads.
So I think the answer
is haven't really
been looking at it.
PAUL SAXMAN: I can't say that
I'm familiar with it.
LES VOGEL: All right.
Who's got another question?
All right, it's going to
be a short day today.
Oh, here er go.
CHRIS: Good timing.
LES VOGEL: Perfect
timing indeed.
CHRIS: Do you want me
to just state it?
LES VOGEL: Yes.
Might as well.
CHRIS: OK.
So I built a Samsung TV
app, and I'd like to
port it, as I mentioned.
Samsung has two types of apps.
They have regular apps
and ticker apps.
Ticker apps are essentially
apps that are overlaid on
regular TV content, whereas
normal apps are taking up the
entire screen.
So what I'd like to know is
I was just reviewing the
PhoneGap document that
you pointed out,
and that looks great.
I'm wondering if there's a way
that I can take a PhoneGap app
and overlay it on regular TV?
If there's anything special I
need to do, or if I would need
to look at building that as a
regular Android application,
as a Java based application
or where I should look?
LES VOGEL: Yeah.
You definitely are going to
have to do an Android app.
So we've been kind of
restricting talking about how
to overlay, but that's what
developers really want to do.
So there are two ways
we talk about it.
One is if you send an intent to
change the channel changing
intent and using the
content provider.
And then you can fire a second
intent about a half second to
a second later to your app to
come forward and then the
activity that comes forward
should have apparent
background except where
you want content.
That has the drawback that
the remote controls
don't work and such.
We've recently found another
way that none of us have
tried, but Paul has an idea.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
So Android has a feature
called the
System Alert Windows.
And the System Alert Windows
are a way to actually bring
Windows in front of other
applications.
The issue with it is though
is that these tend to
be annoying to users.
And they're there all
the time unless you
[? exit or erratically ?]
close them.
But if you want to look into it,
if you just Google search
System Alert Window with
underscores in between, then
you should be able to find
some documentation on
setting those up.
They're not very well documented
even in Android I
think just because
they're not--
LES VOGEL: There is a Stack
Overflow article.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
I think you'll find something
in Stack Overflow as well.
But yeah, System Alert Windows
are another way just to bring
a dialogue in front of
running applications.
LES VOGEL: In addition,
you probably
won't have DPad support.
So that's fine for a ticker,
but it's for apps that want
interactivity, it's going to
be a little difficult.
CHRIS: OK.
Not a problem for me.
Thanks.
LEON: So Les, in terms of that
first option, could you post
some kind of code snippet
on that one?
LES VOGEL: Yeah.
Engineering probably won't
want us to do that.
LEON: Oh, OK.
LES VOGEL: That's why I've never
posted comments on this,
though I do talk about
it in the hang outs.
And I don't post in
the hang outs.
But part of it is that we are
trying to let engineering
figure out a standard way that
makes sense for the user.
Because if you have a lot of
apps that do this, it's going
to be a nightmare
for the user.
In my sense, that's
the user's choice.
In that the user is only
going to use what they
feel like they want.
And valuable apps they'll
use and buy.
And other apps, if it's
annoying, they'll turn it off
as long as there's
an easy off/on.
Or they'll delete the app,
or they'll rate it down.
So let's see, Will has asked a
couple questions about this.
WILL: I think when I first asked
you on Stack Overflow
about this issue you basically
said no it wasn't possible.
About the overlay, it's
about the overlay--
overlay, overlap TV. And I just
want to put my vote in to
say that that is something that
is a great promise for
Google TV in that you can
enhance live TV. You could
make comments on what's
happening.
That's something that I hope
that you guys really embrace.
Because I think that a lot
of cool apps could
be made with that.
Although, what you say is true,
if you start throwing
things in front of live TV, it
can be a horrible experience
if you do it the wrong way.
So I would just hope that
you guys are trying to
push that to happen.
Because I think it opens
up a lot of doors.
And obviously people
want to do it.
So don't hold back.
LES VOGEL: Yeah, no we
understand that.
And that's the point is that
we want innovation.
But it's figuring out the
right way to innovate.
And we don't want to create
a situation where
it turns off users.
We do understand.
That's, as I said, why
I'm OK talking about
it in a hang out.
But I don't want to publish
anything until
engineering is happy.
CHRIS: And for the record,
Samsung TV supports it.
And it was an awful experience
getting it working.
So you can go two ways, right?
You can release it in a bad
way, or you can release it
slowly in a good way.
LES VOGEL: How was it awful?
Was it just the programing or
the experience for users?
CHRIS: Their process is you have
to build something and
push it in to the emulator
and test it there.
And then you can push it up to
the TV. The emulator only
works on Windows.
And basically the app worked
on the emulator and did not
work on the TV. And I
could not figure out
why for days, weeks.
So it just is a miserable
experience.
There's just a lot of things
that are lacking in their
documentation.
It looks like it was
written by an
outsourced development firm.
So it just was a miserable
experience.
LES VOGEL: Well, that's actually
a useful data point.
Thanks.
CHRIS: Sure.
LES VOGEL: All right.
Who's next?
LEON: I've got another one.
So it's kind of related to
something somebody talked
about earlier about being able
to control devices from within
Google TV. But my question
is broader than that.
If you want to do anything that
you can currently do over
Anymote are there any plans on
kind of exposing that as an
API so that you could do
something similar in an
Android app?
LES VOGEL: So can you
ask one more time?
So what exactly are you
trying to accomplish?
LEON: Like remotely, through
Anymote, you can control other
devices and do all kinds of
things even for Google itself
as a system.
What if you wanted to do that
within your Android app
running on Google TV?
PAUL SAXMAN: Oh I see.
Well, you could.
You just have to actually
implement the client code in
your app, right?
It would get really
messy though.
I don't know how that would--
LEON: Well, for example by
controlling other devices,
currently, I can only do that
from my mobile app.
I have to send a signal, and it
gets translated somewhere
within Google TV. I
don't have that
capability as an app, right?
PAUL SAXMAN: Right.
So you want to do TV as a
client or Google TV as a
client to another device.
LEON: Exactly.
PAUL SAXMAN: So you could pull
the Anymote libraries in into
an application and
use it that way.
That would probably
be rather complex.
I think your best bet would be
to do what makes sense just
because I don't think we have
anything in the near term plan
for something like that.
But we do have a protocol if
you have a dish device, we
have a parent protocol between
Google TV and dish devices
that kind of works, I think,
how you're saying.
That's how the DVR commands
are actually sent between
Google TV and the dish device.
That protocol is not
open sourced or not
published on the web.
So we can look into seeing if
that is publishable as well.
The only issue with that
though is that the API
developers, you'd want your app
to actually use the API on
the device to communicate
with the device.
So it's another layer
of complexity.
We'll run it by our product
development team.
LES VOGEL: His app goes remote
control [? change the ?]
device and then the device does
whatever he wants it to.
PAUL SAXMAN: Right,
but let's say
controlling a DVR, for example.
We can do that with dish
devices because we have
parring between Google TV
and the dish device.
But parring between any app and
any device, I think it's
something that we don't
have standardized yet.
I think it's kind of up to
developers right now to kind
of implement something
to do that.
But we can see about potentially
doing something
that would kind of make it
a little easier to use.
LES VOGEL: Let's see.
There are two things here.
We have a question about the
market TV. When you're done
with [? twist ?] that's
Chris [? Hollis. ?]
I'll add him to our hang out.
So that he can--
LEON: Regarding the market app,
last week you said there
is some work being done on it
because I would say at least
the feedback I'm getting
from my users,
that is a big problem.
I mean all kinds of weird
things are going on.
Apps are not getting
installed.
Apps are not getting updated.
And even with the reboot which
seemed to have worked before,
now doesn't seem to always
work anymore.
You get it back to a
state where it can
do the proper thing.
So is that part of this
new software update?
Or is this going to be some kind
of intermediate update
just to fix the market?
LES VOGEL: The software
update probably
has some market fixes.
Osama looked like he
was going to --
OSAMA ALAMI: No.
I just wasn't clear what the
issue is with market?
LES VOGEL: The issues with
market is, if I can paraphrase
you Leon, we know that when you
purchase an app or want to
download an app, it doesn't
always come down immediately.
About 10% of the time, the
signal doesn't get back to the
box to download it.
And I believe there are
fixes coming for that.
But I don't know how specific
and whether it's 100% or not.
OSAMA ALAMI: Yeah.
It is an issue that we are aware
of or rather the market
engineers have been aware of.
And it is something they're
working on.
I don't know if it's been
fixed and in an internal
[? build ?] or not.
Or when it will be pushed out.
But it is something they are
actively working on.
LEON: Is this something that can
be done independently of a
whole system update?
OSAMA ALAMI: An update
to market, it may be.
I don't know.
LES VOGEL: I think the market
could be updated without a
system, but at least
it can on phones.
But I don't know all the details
to make it happen.
And I don't know all the rules
whether the OEMs have to be
involved or not.
LEON: It seems to
come up daily.
That people get stuck
in that mode.
It's really tricky.
And tricky trying to explain
that it's not really the app
that it's the market somehow
that's not doing its thing.
LES VOGEL: Yeah.
And I'm sure that that doesn't
help your ratings.
LEON: Yeah, that's right.
LES VOGEL: So we do understand
that it's an issue.
And hopefully, one of us
will take it back.
Yeah.
All right.
Let's see.
I cannot find my cursor.
Oh, here we are.
That goes that way.
That goes this way.
As soon as I can figure
out how to start
switching people again.
All right.
Let's see, we just had
Brandon join us.
Do you have a question?
BRANDON: There we go.
Well, I was hoping that the user
experience guy was there.
I'm not sure if he is.
LES VOGEL: He was.
We had two of them last week.
BRANDON: Oh, you did?
I missed it.
LES VOGEL: And we had almost
one UX question last week.
So what was your question?
BRANDON: Well, basically a
couple weeks ago, I was
wondering if there was a best
practices or whatever for
interfacing key presses like
arrows on Google TV with the
render script?
Because I have a carousel render
script, but it doesn't
receive any input from
the keyboard.
LES VOGEL: I've asked
someone to do some
sample code for that.
I haven't heard back if
they've started it.
PAUL SAXMAN: So that's something
we're planning to
release some sample code
for this quarter.
BRANDON: Oh, OK.
LES VOGEL: So hopefully
this quarter.
Yeah.
We all want to see that.
Yeah, definitely render
script with key
presses should be a win.
BRANDON: Great, thanks.
LES VOGEL: Anybody else,
another question?
Leon?
You usually have a bunch.
No?
LEON: Did you cover all the
questions in your post?
LES VOGEL: I'll go
through them.
Let's see, Kevin has written in
asking about over the air
recording devices.
The answer depends on your
idea of at a good price.
There are devices on Amazon they
take OTA antenna in and
record to disk and
spit out HTMI.
Cost seems to be about $200.
Christian is explaining--
PAUL SAXMAN: We have one
question on MPEG-2 support.
And I think the issue there
is that it's not
supported by all devices.
It is supported by, I believe,
the TVs and Blu-ray disk
players but not by Buddy
Boxes necessarily.
It's up to the OEM to actually
license the decoder.
So I believe it's required
support for Blu-ray players
with [INAUDIBLE].
The quickest way I think to
know, as far as I remember, is
that if you go to the Android
documentations and look up
the, I think it's in the
supported media types
documentation, not for TV but
for Android, you can actually
look at camera profiles.
And camera profiles will
tell actually what
encoders are available.
And that's actually
a cue to how many
encoders are available.
I don't know how reliable that
is on Google TV, I've
never tested it.
But I think it's a general
strategy for checking for
encoders or decoders
on a device.
I can look that up.
And I'll follow up on the
thread discussion.
LES VOGEL: Here's one for
either one of us.
I don't know the
answer to this.
Alexander asks about
USB mounted drives.
Google TV mounts them as
he writes [? SMTH ?]
like usb.abcd-1234.
How can I get the real name
of a flash drive?
Google TV definitely knows it
because notifications I can
see the synced USB storage
quote label.
So one of us needs to look that
up in the source code.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, I don't
know the answer to that.
Probably best posted
on Stack Overflow.
LES VOGEL: Yeah, if you post
it on Stack Overflow, we'll
look it up for you.
Use #Google-TV. OK.
And Chris, we answered
your question about--
we mentioned PhoneGap, but also
straight Android apps
work well too.
OK.
There are also besides this hang
out, there are Google TV
product managers who hang out.
And so for Roy they are the
ones who you can ask about
Gmail, YouTube, movies,
Google Maps,
Google Earth, and Google+.
That's not our bailiwick.
And UI changes as well
are in their area.
PAUL SAXMAN: That's
not our what?
What was that word you used?
LES VOGEL: Bailiwick.
PAUL SAXMAN: I have never
heard that before.
LES VOGEL: Yes.
OK.
Google it.
PAUL SAXMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
LES VOGEL: Yeah.
PAUL SAXMAN: Military term.
LES VOGEL: Oh, OK.
Someone else?
WILL: Yeah, I have a question.
This is my partner developer
asking it.
We're working with the queriable
guide, the TV Guide,
and we're wondering if Google's
going to have their
own-- if it will be an app,
like a built in app in the
Google TV where it would be a
guide rather than something
that we would build to
query and display?
I'm not sure if that's clear.
I'm not sure if I can--
LES VOGEL: OK.
The guide and channel listing
is licensed material.
So the TV and movies app
has some of that
information in it.
With the next release, we're
going to be adding the TMSID
into the content listing
provider.
So if you were to license data
from Tribune, you can take
that TMS ID and get a lot of
information about the title,
the pictures, descriptions, what
episode it is, and more.
WILL: I wonder if that's how
Plex does all that information
that it gathers.
It sounds like it could be.
I don't know.
Plex does a really good job at
when you have a file that it
recognizes as some show, it
really does a really good job
at populating a description,
a picture of it.
It's really cool.
LES VOGEL: I can't tell
you about Plex.
But I suspect Buddy TV,
that's how it works.
LEON: So, Les, in terms of that
ID, are you saying that
it will just be an extra column
in the current content
provider listing?
LES VOGEL: Yes.
But I haven't actually looked
at the new data.
And I wasn't planing to write
the documentation for it.
I was hoping someone else
in the room might.
They're not speaking up,
so I'm not going
to call them out.
LEON: So the ID, does it refer
to just the channel or are you
saying that it actually tells
you about the current show?
LES VOGEL: Well, you get the
row for each channel.
And it will be, as I understand
it-- and again,
this is not the area
that I looked in.
And as I said, no one
is speaking up.
But it's supposed to have the
TMS ID of the current show.
LEON: Oh, OK.
Well, that's really good
news actually.
LES VOGEL: Yeah.
And then with that, you can
licence the data with Tribune
and work it out.
PAUL SAXMAN: We're not 100% sure
it's the current show.
So we'll get back
to you on it.
And then exactly
what's in it--
LEON: Yeah, because that could
be very interesting.
I've done stuff like that
before, but the ID
would be a nice hook.
PAUL SAXMAN: Right.
Yeah, we had other developers
and kind of partners ask about
actually just knowing who the
broadcast provider is.
So knowing if you're on AT&T
Universe or if you're on
Comcast, San Francisco.
So that TMS ID we can share.
So other information about the
channel line up, the specific
channel lineup or, well,
actually that is the
channel line up.
But the programing guide,
we don't have
information for it yet.
So what's on or what's playing
in the future is something
that you'd have to derive
from the channel ID.
LES VOGEL: Right, and that also
is not giving you what
they're currently watching.
LEON: Yeah, no, I understand.
LES VOGEL: Because we don't
necessarily know that because
it's [? decoupled ?] box.
LEON: So you guys still are
working on a solution for that
for the future?
LES VOGEL: Which part of I can't
talk about unannounced
activities--
Sorry.
WILL: It seems like if it was
your regular cable box, it'd
be right there though.
That'd be perfect.
LES VOGEL: Yeah.
Right.
We got that.
That ain't my department,
however.
OK.
Let's see, reading
through these.
We talked about MPEG-2
already.
We talked about MPEG-2.
Talked a lot about MPEG-2.
OK.
I think we've covered
all these questions.
I see one more thing in
my feed from Paul,
two more from Paul.
Yeah.
We agree with that one.
The problem with not joining in
and asking long questions
is, it's really hard for me to
read it, figure out what's
essential, and having all
of you sitting there.
So basically, Paul is
asking or made a
comment about overlays.
And talking about Comcast
Guide and TiVo guide.
OK.
I don't actually see
a question in here.
But I invited Paul
to the hang out.
So you're welcome to join
me on air and we
can tease that out.
OK.
Any other questions?
WILL: So just a general
question.
What kind of questions are you
looking for in the hang out?
Because a lot of times I feel
like it's a technical hang out
and those kind of questions are
better asked on somewhere
like Stack Overflow.
So I try to ask a different--
I asked a lot of marketing
questions last week.
I guess my general question is
what kind of questions are you
looking for or--
PAUL SAXMAN: I think we are
looking for technical
questions or discussion on any
problems you're having
developing for Google TV. What
our hang out is not looking
for is any product questions
about specific apps on the
platform or future plans for
what the next version of the
platform will look like.
So we are a technical team,
and we're here to support
application developers.
So anything that falls
under that category,
we're happy to answer.
LES VOGEL: That also includes
helping market
your apps or monetize.
So it crosses into the marketing
business aspects if
you want it to.
WILL: I have a similar
question about that.
Right now my app has
two versions.
It has a free version
and a paid version.
And I'm going to collapse them
down into one and do what you
said last week which was provide
an add-on feature
that's going to be the
paid part of it.
It's going to be eventually
just one app.
But my guys who have already
bought the paid one, I'm a
little worried about them
because they're already on.
I guess I still have
to maintain two.
But that's kind of like
my dilemma right now.
But my app is already out
in the world right now.
So I guess I'm stuck with two.
The next one will only be one.
And your idea last week
about having an
add-on or in purchase--
offering it free and add-on.
I really took that to heart.
I think that's a smart
way of doing it.
LES VOGEL: Yeah.
In app purchasing
is a real win.
Let's see.
What you might consider is you
can do the in app purchasing
through your server.
So if you were to release one
like an app engine server with
the credentials--
of course you'd have to ask the
permission of your already
purchased apps.
So basically, you do your own
license validation server.
And then your in app purchasing
can track, rather
than pass the in app token only
to the app, you pass in
app token all the way to your
server and authenticate.
So basically, you release
a version that captures
credentials, of course with
permission and explaining what
you're doing.
And then a week or two later
after you've had sufficient
everybody's upgraded, so it
might be a month or two, you
go to the in app purchasing
version.
And you are validating
credentials
against their email.
So you are kind of breaking
a little bit of the in app
purchasing, but you've got
a way to enable your app.
Does that make sense?
WILL: Yeah, it does.
LES VOGEL: And the Android folks
have content talking
about server enabled
in app purchasing.
Because that's where I got it.
WILL: Gottcha.
I'll check it out.
Thank you.
LES VOGEL: Let's see, Chris is
asking is there a reason we
cannot use PiP, a technical
one or otherwise?
Yeah, fundamentally engineering
didn't provide a
public API for it.
CHRIS: So I guess my question
is more it might be on the
roadmap, it's not something like
OEMs are saying we never
will allow that.
It's more of a just hasn't
been attended to yet.
LES VOGEL: Yeah.
That might be a good way
to characterize it.
I can't tell you.
I'm not confirming that
it's on a road map.
CHRIS: Sure.
Yeah, that's fine.
LES VOGEL: OK.
CHRIS: I should have just not
even have asked the question,
but anyway thanks.
LES VOGEL: No.
It's good to pester us with
these kinds of things, I don't
mean pester.
But basically, if you remind us
over and over again, we can
go to engineering and say every
hang out we get told
this is an issue.
PAUL SAXMAN: Sometimes
along those lines.
It's is really helpful for us
if we hear kind of use cases
in addition to kind of what
your feature request is.
PiP mode is kind of an
interesting one because a lot
of developers want PiP mode so
they can embed video or have
the impression that video is
embedded in their application.
But that might not be the
optimal solution.
There could be other ways
to actually get
video into your app.
So if you can kind of share
with us what you'd like to
accomplish from an application
developer, from a user
experience standpoint, we can
kind of distill that down to
something that we can bring to
the product development team
and kind of drive requirements
for the product.
CHRIS: So the app that I built
for the Samsung TV is
essentially an app that allows
you to get more collaborative
around live sporting events.
And so the ticker application,
it essentially overlays a
scoreboard.
People are essentially using
their phones to participate in
kind of voting on match ups.
This specific sport is MMA or
UFC mixed martial arts.
And so the app allows you go to
your phone and choose the
match ups that you like.
And then from there, there's a
scoreboard overlaid on the
live TV such that when the event
is occurring, you're
seeing the scoreboard updated
in real time.
And so for that application,
the Samsung ticker works
really well because it allows
you to overlay on that.
So I mean I like to look for
the simplest solution.
And so when I was looking at
the documentation a few
minutes ago, it looked like
PiP might be an option.
But I'm not attached to it.
It sounds like the other option
you suggested, Les, is
probably a better one--
using an intent to
launch the app.
LES VOGEL: Well, the nice thing
about using an intent is
then you can focus on your sport
and you know what is up,
especially if you license TMS
data, you can get to the right
channel, you guide them, and
when they want out of your
app, they quit it.
They have regular television
again.
And so it then becomes channel
or sport focused.
Because if it is not live TV,
you might have other content
that you take them to, a
different kind of activity.
So on the historical
or future events.
Right?
So you can do more by
making it an app.
And that's my story, and
I'm sticking with it.
OK.
So we're almost out of time.
I posted a link.
If any of you are in Canada,
Paul Carff and I are going to
be doing a developer lab in
Toronto on the 7th of March.
So feel free to sign
up for that.
And otherwise, Google runs on
the short meeting idea.
So I'm going to end it here
unless anyone's got something
else to say.
That's all.
Thank you.
Bye bye.